previously on TV sins dams more than
Assam Chile this job is eating me alive
I can't breathe anymore since we find
out he's actually giving the speech
inside the store what does this cut to
him walking outside about doing the best
speech from Donnie Brasco actually 10 of
me you're doing the best speech from
Donnie Brasco math must not be Peralta
strong suit because there are clearly
more than 10 monitors showing his face
also best speech from Donnie Brasco let
me introduce you to something I like to
call I'm at the dock yeah did the thief
also steal this guy in the background
and return him because he wasn't there
in the previous shop he got lucky no I
got here five minutes before you and
figured that in this gigantic electronic
store there had to be at least one
working camera and jake is just bringing
this up now but the thieves still out
there horrible and professionalism aside
the owner of the store is there with
them and is witnessing all this
incompetence you know what this title
car could do for us tell us the day of
the week I'm over here thinking it's
8:31 on the same morning that Santiago
and Peralta investigated a robbery you
know from 30 seconds ago but it's not
that day it's a new day and we only know
this to be true because everyone is
wearing new clothing I'm having to do a
detective work to keep the daily street
more knotted in two minutes in I'm not
saying that cops don't have these kinds
of case solving competitions no matter
how unprofessional and frankly gross
that might be but it's no less to sit
hidden was flan Charles thinks it was
flying I think was butterscotch pudding
that is clearly part of a discarded
gummy bear and I hate you so for making
me have to think about this for any time
at all we focus on the murder and not
the old person gunk Terry Crews acting
in this episode makes tiny Lister look
like Orson Welles tell us about the new
captain captain ho will be here soon
he'll want to introduce himself since we
learned that Terry knows captain Holt
why in the wouldn't he'd give his team
at least some info so they can make a
good impression
it's as if Terry as a fan of sitcom high
jinks and wants to make sure they occur
just wish captain McGinley never left he
was the best I know it's the pilot and
hasn't found its fulham at this point
given all the wushi flashbacks this
episode is really scrubs II isn't it
like don't you get the sense these two
characters could easily be played by
Zach Braff and Sarah Shaw if you look
closely enough at captain Holt's uniform
you can see a black WTC commendation on
his badge this is a nice touch from the
casting Department because it's a bar
awarded to any responders on September
11th 2001 however it's also supposed to
be worn at the highest level in the
badge area with the exception of the
American flag so it should be up one
more spot mannequin do Terry Crews you
can laugh at this physical comedy bit
involving a baked good I'm over here
looking at this horrifying Tetris esque
crime against paperwork maybe these are
useless documents about plumbing repair
on the third floor from 1978 but god
damn someone scoop these files out of
this locker and stick them in one of the
hundreds of boxes this precinct has all
over the place where do we start we
start with him knie man I know this
pilot needs to get to the point but the
only reason Holt is focusing on Peralta
is that he was making an innocuous joke
about the incoming captain why not start
with Rosa and her potentially dangerous
anger issues or homeboy that can't even
handle a muffin
speaking of ties where's yours me more
in this cast of very very funny people
the usually very very serious Andre
Braugher
is the standout the majority of the time
which deserves a sit off having said
back how in the ever-lovin did Holt know
that hot rod wasn't wearing a tie since
he just walked up behind him sure he
could have been to it that would place
him in the Batman pantheon of detectives
and I'm not sure we're there yet Citizen
Kane is terrible pick a good movie man
Rosa a little better movie tastes even
cinemasins wouldn't send Citizen Kane
what doomed Santiago and Peralta riding
on this bed of theirs I will tell you on
six conditions God can you imagine
having six things in your mind
immediately ready to demand at the drop
of a hat I'm gonna try this mmm
unsupervised dancing in a room full of
cats at daily cheese plate exact change
for the vending machine uninterrupted
daily naps um that's all I have in me if
he gets more arrests she has to go on a
date with him he guarantees he it will
end in sex 2013 office bets that could
and should get you fired in 2020 hello
you know what's your name Nino's show or
a movie with an SNL cast member or has
other SNL cast members make cameos
cliche also Fred Armisen plays a
character of unknown foreign origin with
a cartoonish accent at a TV show cliche
wall street journal' on the doormat top
floor apartment
20 bucks says this guy's like a hot
eligible bachelor I'm guessing it's more
likely he's a time traveler because New
York world is a newspaper that has been
defunct since 1931 then while you're out
you can buy yourself a time Oh actually
sir I'm wearing a tie right now check it
out why is Captain Holt bound
immediately firing Peralta I'm either
too drunk to find this funny or too
horny to laugh how can they be at the
grocery store and going door-to-door at
the apartment complex at the same time
someone's lying I'm gonna find out who
my first line of questioning will be
aimed at the continuity department do
you hate your job I'm questioning the
validity of these flavor labels I demand
to see the manager and taste tests to be
sure that they are what they say they
are also for someone who prizes food
enough to mother kill a dude for a
gourmet ham this [ __ ] is being
extremely careless with this product
also no one in this bean deli is getting
involved are they all in on the ham
highest with Ratko so no I did not brief
you and yes he did get away he got away
because you decided to stop chasing him
and I can't figure out why Ratko ran
around the corner of the counter and out
the door so what was stopping the
detectives from doing the same lucky man
I wish I could get a sign here full-time
keep playing hand puppets at your desk
via webcam on a secured police network
and you will in 1981 they caught the
disco strangler and at 1608 we're seeing
our fifth flashback and honestly I'm too
exhausted by character whiplash to be
impressed with the capture of a disco
yo-yo killer I mean if that's the sort
of thing I'm supposed to be impressed
with Geraldo's break in the case comes
after searching files for the words
Serbian and rap in real life this would
have taken such a long time but the
non-bench detectives would have already
found the perp after asking the employer
for his home dress get in here bring
everyone and a camera that's not
necessary why wouldn't you just sit back
down another flashback and yes I already
sinned having too many of them but this
one is a flashback to things that happen
in this episode only 14 minutes ago
don't treat me like I'm an idiot
Brooklyn nine-nine
I don't know what thinking happens and
stuff yeah you just go to the movies for
now why is the entire staff of
detectives including a god damn
commanding captain out on this stakeout
sure it's a big case but the kind of
organization doesn't leave at least one
[ __ ] behind you know
/ I'm amazing but you're not very good
at dressing yourself
that's an armhole and the best that
you're putting your head through is if
you take a look to your left you'll see
detectives Boyle and Diaz right there is
detective Santiago and behind you is
Captain Holt's fun cool right but how
does he know where any of his team would
be in the storage mace there's so little
communication amongst them about
planning and there's been no sign of
those techy inner ear communicators I'm
much better with the scene be if he had
said Santiago was on the left but it was
actually captain Holt that seems so much
more on character for Peralta at this
point never took off the speedo big
mistake it is inside me Jake made a big
deal earlier about how he changed his
clothes to be more comfortable at the
stakeout but neglected to remove the
uncomfortable speedo it's almost like
the show is trading reality for cheap
laughs and I expect more from the team
behind the modern classic 22 Jump Street
my name a sweat
good news for all you murder fans
[Music]
during her interview I deduced using
expert detective work that she had
something super gross on her chin the
robot voice you were doing when you
implied I'm a rule-following robot I
want to hear it again there are no
strings on me captain hey welcome to the
murder what are you doing here I like to
know where my detectives are - you
people are d-squad d4 dirtbags when I
say hey dirtbags
that means you which mean I am your
[Applause]